nouveau rebondissement dans la sphère
dix condamnés à perpétuité pour le
meurtre de deux enfants 86 un commandant
de police à la retraite
présent au moment de la reconstitution
des crimes en 87 expriment de sérieux
doutes et des remords ce témoignage
capital intervient en plein délibéré de
la cour de cassation qui dira le 28 juin
s'il ya lieu ou non de réviser le procès
au maire stragier a fait toute sa
carrière dans la police à metz il était
commandant c'est lui qui spontanément
lumière a souhaité revenir sur les lieux
de la tragédie 1986 montigny-lès-metz à
cet endroit deux enfants sont
sauvagement assassiné en 1987 au même
endroit
patrick 10 alors présumé coupable
participent à la reconstitution
ce jour-là au maire stragier assurent la
sécurité des lieux
il se trouve à quelques mètres de
patrice 14 ans après les faits dans un
long entretien qu'il nous a accordé aux
mères ce tragique revient sur cette
reconstitution qui selon lui ne collait
pas à la réalité
à l'époque tué le brigadier qui était de
service de permanence qui était le
premier à viser des faits sur le 17 à se
rendre sur place
présent également lors de la
reconstitution s'assure j'ai constamment
et se révoltent et même contre le fait
que l'on ne patrick dils en quelque
sorte finissait par faire tout et
n'importe quoi et notamment s'insurger
de voir que les petites poupées qui
représentait à l'époque les du team
qu'il avait été chargé de remettre en
place ce n'était pas comme ça tout aussi
troublant il se souvient de cette
vieille dame venue l'interpeller sur
place elle me dit tout de go alors
monsieur cédons pas le vieux monsieur
qu'on a pu avec sa bicyclette surprise
je suis revenu sur mes pages dites moi
madame comment qu'elle me vieux monsieur
avec une bicyclette
bah oui elle se retourne vers ses autres
collègues dit bah oui il dit mais
attendez vous l'avais dit à la police
ben oui oui d'envoi la betty donc la
police et on vous a entendu pas de
réponse
le commissaire rien vous a fait venir à
l'hôtel de police
non on n'a jamais revu personne car en
1997 avec cet élément nouveau la
présence de francis heaulme sur les
lieux du crime le jour des faits omer
stragier établi des rapprochements des
rapprochements avec le faciès édenté de
francis heaulme
et ce vélo qu'il ne quittait jamais cet
après-midi quand il découvre le
témoignage
les révélations d'un maire stragier où
visiblement embarrassé bernard verley à
l'époque chargé de l'enquète qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
je pense qu'une chose que si un
fonctionnaire de police a eu ces
informations il ya 14 ans il ya quatorze
ans après dire à vue
je suis un peu ému et d'en dire un peu à
la presse qu'il a eu des informations
lors de la reconstitution et qui n'en
fait seulement état aujourd'hui je
dirais que c'est un drôle de policiers
est ce que vous avez eu connaissance de
ce témoignage de vieilles dames non on a
entendu des vidanges en entrant dans on
a on a vu en tout et pour tout
quinze mille personnes dans le cadre de
cette affaire là voilà on a remué tout
montigny ddv d'arbres dans la vue des
dizaines et des dizaines mais voilà la
liste des révélations troublantes ne
s'arrête pas là il y a quelques jours
nous avons rencontré marguerite posocco
elle affirme avoir vu patrick dils le
jour du drame que vous êtes en train de
dire qu'à aucun moment il ne s'est
dirigé vers les enfants jamais jamais
jamais jamais jamais le 28 juin prochain
la chambre criminelle de la cour de
cassation se prononcera sur la révision
ou non du procès de patrick dils
ces témoignages de dernière minute
conduire ont ils un jour à la vérité
chacun attend